[Music]
I'm currently testing out a new Sony a7
3 I'm messing with a bunch of different
settings and color grading I am not very
good at color grading so I've been
trying out a couple of different things
the testing out some different picture
profiles and some different settings so
if there is a favorite look that you
guys have in this video please let me
know your favorite timecode and put that
in the comments below
right now this is being filmed just on a
normal no picture profile settings super
basic no color grading now right hop to
another look I don't even remember what
picture profile use so even if I wanted
to copy this I don't even remember oh my
god I I just opened the door to be like
look at Brie she's mopping the car oh
okay I got a ma well it never looks bad
timing oh oh no
[Music]
we are in Tahoe and I'm so excited
because Jenna and I have always wanted
to come here and finally we have made
the trek out also with the rest of my
family they're in town from Pennsylvania
and yesterday we wanted this really fun
hike to it was called cascade Falls and
for whatever reason I had a microphone
setting on that was kind of weird I'll
show you guys a little bit of that right
now and apologizing in advance for the
audio and after that we're gonna be
hopping on these gondolas and heading up
to the top of the mountain when I told
my friends that us commute Tahoe
everyone was like hey are you gonna ski
are you gonna snowboard and I said no
I've never done either one of those
before and also my mom won't let us so
we're gonna have to come back and do it
when she's not present I don't want to
get yelled at by my mom yeah I'm an
adult but moms are always right I was
just thinking that that was you and it
was like maybe it's not Brianne but I
interview you for a second sure how are
you I'm good I'm trying to film the
Falls oh yeah yeah you haven't been to
one of my videos in a very long time I
have not are you excited about this yep
tell me more about how excited you are
I'm creating it let's talk about more of
the exciting new ideas right okay I move
right now she doesn't want to be in my
movie
[Music]
hmm
cascade Falls of desolation jeez I don't
know what's wrong John one of my
favorite things is Brienne likes to
Google really cool hikes but then she
ends up leading us into a random place
that is not where you should be at all
which I have a feeling
[Music]
not quite to the falls yet I think we're
like two-thirds the way there it's
starting to snow and Brienne is trying
to get a picture of herself doing a
handstand we're never gonna make it back
I'm actually gonna stop filming and I
will see you guys in whatever we happen
to do after this hike 1 2 3 go
[Music]
we are gone the lies this is the
heavenly whoa we just hopped up here at
the observation deck and it is so pretty
it's actually not that cold I thought I
would be a little bit chillier but it's
definitely not more you're not going to
be complaining like I did in Austria
we're still in California probably 14
seconds ago I said that it wasn't that
cold
I retract every single statement that I
said cuz now I'm freezing once I got
over to this side wow this view is
amazing you are about 9,000
Oh
I think I might be really into snake -
the cold pulla not allowed mom when a
lot of ski our way she said hey you
gotta get snowboard down that mountain
Jenna okay well we saw it and now we go
if I tell them guys I am so excited
because right now we are going to meet
one of my new favorite youtubers and I
actually just found his channel because
I was looking for a bunch of blends
reviews and for the past couple of
months all of his videos kept showing up
when I was searching for things for my
Sony camera whether it's Lots color
grading anything and now here we are
because I basically stalked him all the
way to Tahoe was crazy cuz I didn't even
know that you lived in Tahoe until I did
a little more research and then here we
are like this is the internet this is I
don't actually live here I just saw that
she was coming inside
my mom was like wait you're going to
meet some people from the internet
because we're here with my family I'm
like yeah that's that's what we do
that's what I've been doing for the past
however long I've been making videos so
can you tell them a little about your
channel so my channel is mainly about
cinematic filmmaking
I used Sony cameras so if you guys are
Sony camera shooters come check it out
but yeah it's all about cinematic travel
videos all that good stuff if you're
interested definitely stop by cody blue
if you search me it'll come right up and
it's so funny because I didn't even
recognize you but I recognized you
because you're in all of the video
model right here my favorite quote I
think one of your one of the videos is
you're like I always have to be like the
most difficult job it's you're like I
have to always put makeup yeah it's
ready right shirt yeah yeah I ain't
never wear makeups always my hair's
always in a bun you know I'm always in
workout clothes oh yeah it's just it's
horrible he really did film something
like do I have to look presentable
can I look like main you're like maybe
it like a little presentable like
there's like a fine line it's like
sometimes we'll look nice and other
times it's like wow I don't even
recognize you
I'm sorry but yeah this is so awesome
but thanks for showing us around Tahoe
makes you're meeting up thanks for the
first youtuber that I've met up with so
really this is monumental guys market
that's we're not gonna mark it here but
yeah we're definitely come back to Tahoe
if you guys ever come to LA come hang
out I'll show you some fun stuff and
yeah I forgot go to the beach now okay I
lied we already went to the beach and I
was going to try to fake this this was
gonna be the intro to us going to the
beach because it was so cold before yep
the Internet's a lie we already went to
the beach but here's the beach footage
okay go
[Music]
everything to see why are you so bundled
up at the beach because it's freezing
okay wait so what's this beach called
this is Nevada Beach okay you're in Lake
Tahoe it is the secret this is a secret
guys secret reaching there pretty much
everybody knows about right it's the
secret most popular beach in Tahoe find
it so I've also been talking about how
bad I am at color grading and you've got
some lots don't you I do there uh yeah
they're pretty popular if you guys want
to check them out or if your Sony
shooters especially there specifically
for Sony camera so you guys will
definitely like them yeah that's the
hard part good finding all these other
ones I'm like oh this looks so bad on my
footage I'll send them to you okay yeah
I'll put a link in the description and
you guys can check them out okay let's
go have dinner
[Music]
a lot of you guys have been talking with
the new Samsung Galaxy j2 Pro I heard it
on Amazon so I've got it here I've also
got the Samsung Galaxy S nine and of
course and we're gonna go on a hike and
I'm gonna test out all three of these
phones I did a quick unboxing it looks
just like any sort of basic own
headphones microUSB cable oh the reason
that it's so light is just half of the
phone is right here got the charging
brick right let's go and hop in the car
I'll charge this thing on the way
[Music]
you guys are often encouraging me to try
other phones other than the flagship
devices like the s9 or the FM 10 Oh
[Music]
let's take this thing for a spin all
right we're testing out the front-facing
video here on the j2 Pro oh no I'm
feeling vertical that's it's not
acceptable
[Music]
thanks for watching my blog this brings
the slug to an end
genna's over there we were playing duo's
but then I died like two seconds in and
now she's still playing twelve people so
I just heard a solo match but that's all
I've got to say I'll see you guys in my
next video let's go these doors are
opening not waiting for anybody
[Music]
[Applause]